les bennes phone c'est une tradition des
campagnes électorales
malgré la pandémie on a pu voir les
chefs aller à la rencontre des électeurs
ça a été extrêmement agréable de pouvoir
voir les gens évidemment il faut suivre
les directives de santé publique mais ce
que les chefs respecte vraiment toutes
les directives
[Musique]
la réponse est non pour les personnes
qui sont pleinement vacciner la santé
publique fédérale indique que la
distanciation physique et le port du
masque ne sont pas obligatoires lors des
rassemblements en plein air par contre
elle dit qu'il faut suivre les
directives mises en place par les
autorités locales au québec la santé
publique demande aux gens qui n'habitent
pas dans un même foyer de conserver une
distance de 1 m tant à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur
justin trudeau et john meeting ont donc
contrevenu à cette règle lors de leur
passage dans la province mais au moins
ils portent le masque ce qui est
recommandé quand la distanciation est
impossible on fait tout ce qu'on peut on
a des protocoles comme vous avez vu que
je porte mon as tu le temps quand je
suis devant
justin trudeau a quant à lui été prise
en défaut une deuxième fois en
participant hier un rassemblement
extérieur en ontario où la limite de 100
personnes a été dépassé deux choix
s'offrent à vous depuis le début de la
campagne le chef conservateur et rino
tulsi largement tenu à l'écart du public
le chef du bloc québécois et françois
blanchet lui tente de garder ses
distances avec les électeurs quand ils
participent à des événements extérieurs
moi je donne pas le coude de jeu
j'embrasse peau je donne pas la
meilleure je fais pas le le petit point
en vaut éviter les highfive si les chefs
pleinement vacciner et masqués ont peu
de chances de contracter la co vide les
experts s'inquiètent davantage pour les
gens nous vacciner qui pourraient se
retrouver dans leur rassemblement
[Musique]